well now long before called in mania so
called a wave of anti-austerity began
sweeping parts of Europe Greece was at
the forefront of that of course with the
election of left-wing sir it's after his
election in january the greek Finance
Minister was Yanis varoufakis he became
about as close to a celebrity as many
politicians get but after seven months
of fierce negotiations with Greece's
creditors in the European Union he
resigned well yeah this fellow Farkas
joins me now from West London and a very
good morning to you and as I mentioned
anti-austerity parties what parallels do
you see between your own syriza party
and the Labour Party in the UK under
jeremy corbyn there are some broad
similarities in the sense that I believe
that the body politic both in Greece and
the United Kingdom and elsewhere in
Canada as it turned out quite recently
have had a gutful of the old style of
politics of the assumption that the
weaker members of society must suffer
the costs of a crisis to which they
contributed nothing at all and that
there is no alternative other than a
continuing diminution of prospects for
the majority of the people that is the
comparison but on the other hand we have
to be vigilant about the great
differences between Greece and generally
member states of the eurozone and
Britain Britain fortunately for Britain
and maybe for the rest of us is not part
of the eurozone so in this country the
forces of progress face quite different
challenges and also have access to
rivers that are lacking in places like
my country back home in Greece I want to
ask you about that because it was the
great well maybe unanswered question but
let's hear it from you you said there
fortunately for Britain it's not in the
euro was never part of Syria's program
the grease should even think about
leaving the euro and then have control
over your own currency and all the
devaluation and other levers that you
can have at your disposal well it is
important to draw a very sharp
distinction between on the one hand the
verdict that we should not have been in
the euro this was a review that I held
in the 1990s and I lost a lot of friends
in Greece due to my opposition to our
entering the eurozone but we need to as
I said we need to distinguish this
sharply from the view that we should get
out the point I'm making is this we
should not have entered but once we're
in the path that led this to the
eurozone doesn't exist anymore so if we
try to back up to reverse along the same
path we will fall off a cliff exiting a
monetary union is utterly hazardous
operation it's equivalent of announcing
a devaluation many many months before it
takes place so once in you have to stay
within and try to fight as hard as you
can maybe default within the monetary
union in order to extract from Brussels
and from Frankfurt a decent agreement to
reframe that the terms of your presence
in the eurozone in such a way as to make
it possible for the dead deflationary
spiral to end and for some glimmer of
hope of recovery and girls to return mr.
banner focus what do you make of the UK
as it debates its future within Europe
ahead of an in-out referendum I mean
your analysis is that the EU is
anti-democratic that it's run by
authoritarian technocrats yet you feel
the grease should stay and its many in
Britain make that analysis but by large
they're the ones that want to leave let
me be brief in my assessment regarding
the referendum in this country you will
not find many politicians who are US
scathing about Brussels as I am at the
very same time my message to
my friends here in Britain is stay
within and campaign as strongly as
possible in order to change it
retreating back to the nation state is
not an option anymore Britain is simply
going to find itself still constrained
by a malfunctioning European Union
without having any capacity to influence
it and secondly let's face it the moment
you step out of the European Union the
constitutional problems of the United
Kingdom are going to flare up and they
are going to distract this nation from
the task of regaining its boys looking
after the incredible failure with
productivity with investment with
creating decent jobs for the people of
Britain and think of the person in the
pub the man in the pub as I say who now
scapegoats the European Union blaming
Brussels for everything what is he going
to blame everything that will go wrong
on after that and just wanted to ask you
about Portugal you will have seen as we
talk about the spread of anti-austerity
parties in Europe the Portuguese
president refusing to a point to party
that won a majority because of its
anti-eu rhetoric could you interpret
that as anti-democratic well this is
just another example of the crisis of
European democracy the rules of the
eurozone are impossible to implement
because the whole monetary union was
exceptionally battle designed
unfortunately Europe is in denial of
this and the greater the failure of
those rules the greater the
determination of the bureaucrats and the
politicians who are serving in the
bureaucrats rather than vice versa to
implement these rules and the only way
to go against the laws of nature of you
on this to become increasingly
authoritarian and for the democratic
deficit to become greater than ever this
is why what Europe really needs now is a
surge
of democracy what it needs is a movement
of well thinking reasonable European
Democrats to demand from the bureaucracy
to demand from their politicians that
they start respecting a very simple idea
and a very simple principle the
principle of democracy and lastly I more
advice sir for the Labour Party is said
sharing some of your anti-austerity
analysis what about its method of
campaigning and this idea of syriza did
of energizing a new base perhaps an anti
politics base using social media and
other non-traditional methods look
there's no doubt that the media and of
course I accept you from this judgement
the media have been quite toxic in the
way that they covered our campaign for a
modicum of rationality and of economic
reason it is as if they were behaving in
a totalitarian fashion in support of
policies that were absolutely impossible
to justify that was the situation in
Greece and unfortunately I see that
there is also tendency in this country
to undermine the quality of the
conversation once Jeremy Corbyn appeared
on the scene let me just give you an
example the way that he was lambasted
for his idea of a different kind of
quantitative easing people's quantitive
easing when effectively what he was
doing he was reviving a monetarist
agenda even Friedman Milton Friedman had
talked about helicopter money the way
that the quality of the dialogue is
being jeopardized by media which is
absolutely keen to bring down any
radical voice that seems to be stepping
out of the beaten track this is the
tremendous democracy and my advice to
Jeremy Corbyn and actually to every and
any conviction politician is just ignore
the media articulate reasonable position
put it to the people and if you've done
your job
only at articulating a reasonable
position in the end the people who are
going to citizens are going to respond
to it and then the media will have to
follow okay mr virus park is fascinating
talking to you thank you very much
indeed for your time Jana swallowed
Farkas there the former greek Finance
Minister